um sadly
another american journalist has been
killed by russian troops this time maybe
journalist isn't the right word a member
of the media a camera person
and it is getting
very dangerous in ukraine to be a member
of the media mediaite reporting
fox news cameraman killed an attack that
wounded benjamin hall
earlier in the week we talked about the
injury to benjamin hall
we now are learning about
um the death
of uh cameraman pierre zakruski
who was killed outside kiev in ukraine
uh fox news media ceo suzanne scott
announced the tragic news in a note to
colleagues she said zakrewsky 55 years
old and hall were reporting in the
village of orenka when their vehicle was
struck by incoming fire
ukrainian officials say alexandre
kufcinova the producer working with the
fox news team was also killed in the
attack
the notice says dear colleagues it was
great with great sadness and a heavy
heart that we share the news this
morning regarding our beloved cameraman
pierre zakrewski he was killed in urenka
outside of key of ukraine was with
benjamin hall yesterday news gathering
when their vehicle was struck
by incoming fire um the hill also
reporting on this
fox cameraman killed a mid attack in
ukraine
this article um mentions a little bit
more about zakrewsky and uh the degree
to which this is crossing party lines
and you know i think there's a lot of
people may not realize
um
in media very often the camera people
cameraman camera women
around the world
sometimes they're freelance contractors
i mean they may technically be employees
or they may be freelance contractors or
whatever the case may be but the point
is they very often don't subscribe to
the same political views as the media
outlet which they are covering and the
uh understanding is i mean listen
regardless this would be a tragedy and
attacks on on members of the media are
deplorable and and absolutely sickening
and disgusting
but some people reacted by saying well
here's a here's a right winger who got
killed not that it would make it any
less bad
um very often these are sometimes
they're union and internationally
sometimes they're freelance and that
that's just that's just neither here nor
there i think an important point to
mention is that in general
it's dangerous to be a journalist
journalist
not necessarily a camera person
um when russia doesn't like what you're
doing and as dangerous as it has become
on a statistical basis in ukraine so far
we've now had multiple deaths and a
number of members of the media injured
you can also look up the wikipedia
article list of journalists killed in
russia and they actually have a table
that goes by year
and um
the numbers are quite high they're in
the hundreds in the hundreds for
journalists killed
in russia it is not good
here is cnn correspondent scott mclean
uh cnn remember sort of paying tribute
to pierre zakrewski should also point
out that we learned that a long time
photojournalist pierre zakrusky
for fox news
his body was found he's been killed in
keith
yeah that's right the second uh foreign
journalist to be killed pierre was
working for fox news we understand the
correspondent as well uh is in critical
condition according to fox
i actually had opportunity to meet
pierre two years ago when i was in kiev
i can tell you he was extremely popular
in the industry it's pretty small
industry especially on the road with
international journalists everybody
seemed to know him i don't usually drink
a lot when i'm on the road because we're
busy but i can tell you on our last
night
i have a picture with him and we were
three sheets to the wind because he was
just a lovely guy to hang out with and
we were just having a riot hanging out
with the fox guys i ended up running
into him in 2020 uh a few months later
when we were in the lockdown in london
where he was living and
i just remember he was really
trying to get out the door trying to he
was bored sitting around in london
during the lockdown and so i know that
he really loved his job he really loved
the travel he really loved the adventure
obviously this is a tragedy and uh it
seems like he's universally loved in
this industry and i can tell you from my
brief experience with him he was just a
really lovely guy to be around so
there's the personal tragedy someone
died here someone with a family has died
there's also the reality that yes war
journalism
is not without its dangers there's no
question about it but uh it's it's a
small sample this has been a short
engagement so far this invasion of
ukraine by russia uh and and we've you
know the number of people killed is
thankfully low in terms of the raw
number
but on a proportions basis
for how many journalists are there and
how long it's been
russia is not taking particular care not
taking particular care
uh when it comes to members of the media
and it is getting
dangerous enough and keiv that a 36-hour
curfew has been announced
after residential buildings were hit by
heavy shelling so
all part of the tragedy the invasion is
a tragedy the civilians killed a tragedy
members of the media killed it's it's
it's bad uh members you know peop
ukrainian citizens just defending their
country
uh kill it's all absolutely horrifying
and by the way i would say it's also a
tragedy when russian soldiers are sent
without a clue sometimes as to what's
really even going on
and very often
not even wanting or believing that this
is a worthy cause when they are killed i
mean a lot of them are kids as well uh
so it's all tragedy uh let me know what
you think you can find me on twitter at
deepakman we have a packed program for
you today
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video